It is a one-year MBA.
It is distinct from the two-year MBAs, which is the normal model in the States.
It is a pedagogical model which works very well...
...because the students we have tend to be somewhat older, so the average age is 30, 31,...
...so people need at least five years of experience before they come to us.
The normal model is one in which they are highly talented, high calibre people...
...often from blue-chip organisations...
...but who have been specialising up to that point in their career,...
...and they need to develop more general management skills in order to move to the next level.
And effectively, the MBA is a very intensive crash course...
...in getting that very general base in management and leadership.